hi guys
today we're talking about
a ridiculous ass movie yeah that i
absolutely love
i liked the movie it was good
pretty influential movie because there's
a lot of this movie in this movie i was
watching and i'm like what the [ __ ]
and uh a lot of stuff that happens and a
lot of things that are said and the
character a lot of the characters in
these movies inspired other stuff that
you would know
like dieter from sprockets on saturday
night live you know there's a lot of
that in there uh
rocky horror adventure show
yeah i feel like an animator i mean in
particular the one set yeah uh you know
the laboratory set i think
i mean it could just be that rocky
horror picture show was uh homaging you
know kind of hammer films and stuff like
that which this is also imaging but i
kind of feel like the the set in this
is almost exactly like the one a rocky
horror picture show so i think that was
uh deliberate like down to the you know
statues and everything this is a
frankenstein movie produced by andy
warhol it's it's [ __ ] bizarre it's
good though it's good it's [ __ ] once
you get over the fact that you're not
really supposed to take this seriously
this [ __ ] is over the [ __ ] top big
time all right and once you realize that
the tone and everything that this
is just weird and european is possible
you know it's just weird euro trash
movie and it's porn movie basically it's
x-rated
yeah it actually did come out as x-rated
not and not just because of a gore
because it's very gory yeah also um but
yeah
yeah there's a lot of uh there's also a
lot of smut um
yeah but it's all like ironic and over
the top it's not serious it's just like
what yeah this is i kind of feel like
what how you feel about this movie
really has to do with how you're
approaching it because this is
definitely
a movie that
i'm pretty sure was intended to be a
spoof or a black comedy yeah it's a
comedy and if you don't really get that
because honestly i think the even the
idea for this movie which is called
flesh for frankenstein by the way
although i think in the us and in some
other territories it's sometimes called
andy warhol's frankenstein
or frankenstein 3d because it was
initially shot in 3d
uh which i'll get into that in a minute
i haven't seen the 3d version
i well i thought that because there's
some scenes in there where people's like
guts fall out and it comes out like
right at you and i was just kind of like
i'm imagining this was probably supposed
to be 3d originally and indeed it was
so this movie
uh was actually it's called andy
warhol's but andy warhol didn't have a
lot to do with it um he kind of just
like put up some money and he's like
i'll put my name on it just for
marketing purposes obviously because
he's super famous but this was uh
written and directed by his longtime
collaborator paul morrissey who also did
blood for dracula pretty much the same
time
right after they shot this one shutter
just added both of them because uh
vinegar syndrome has just put out like a
really nice
uh two-disc set of this
uh they might have done blood for
dracula too but i'm not really sure but
i've seen this one and i've seen like a
couple reviews of it and it has like the
regular cut and it has the 3d when it
comes with the glasses and everything so
you can watch it 3d if you want to buy
the vinegar syndrome one
so
the apparently the idea for this at
least according to wikipedia actually
came from roman polanski who had also
done like a parody sort of film of the
fearless vampire killers and he's like
they want to do a 3d frankenstein so
he's like we should get paul morrissey
to do it because that would be hilarious
um i think absurd was the word that he
used
so i think from the jump this was
supposed to be
a parody kind of it is very absurdist it
is very camp almost salvador dali level
it is like
and it's
designed to be like deliberately
shocking and deliberately provocative
it's just kind of like they're like
we're gonna put like whatever offensive
[ __ ]
that we can possibly put i mean it's not
probably like offensive nowadays because
this was the 70s but you can tell that
they were definitely trying to go out
and like shock people yeah uh with with
this film
so
the story behind it
is you got uh the wonderful wonderful
yes udokir he shines in this movie this
is a very early role for him i don't
think this was his first movie but it
might have been like among his first
couple if you don't know that name if
you see this guy you'll recognize him
he's in a bunch of horror movies he was
in so he was in over 200 movies he's
just this creepy damn german dude and he
was in this movie in this character in
this movie he's definitely the
inspiration for dieter from sprockets
and he [ __ ] says a lot of the exact
you're spoiling him you know
it's kind of like
a german herbert west you know if you
ever watch reanimator he's like that
he's a
bunch of damn conflicted dichotomies
he's real uptight but then he's [ __ ]
perverse at the same time and
just like theater from his
pockets it's hilarious once you get over
it once you once once
you understand the tone of this movie
you just kind of don't fight it just
roll with it
yeah because it's like [ __ ] weird
says some weird [ __ ] everybody in the
movie all the characters seem to have
inspired other characters like
his wife slash sister yes he's very very
to his sister married to his sister and
they have two kids and they have two
kids she's definitely kind of like uh
the inspiration for the madeleine khan
uh a role in young frankenstein dresses
yeah because she does actually the
outfits that she has mega [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
like this german mega [ __ ] and uh it's a
great character though it's [ __ ] over
the top i don't think she's german i
think she's from i think she's
transylvanian actually or something in
real life or where she's in real life i
think i think i thought she was supposed
to be german in the movie
see yeah because he's german yeah and so
it's his sister yeah so yeah this was uh
yeah that would be weird if uh your if
your brother is
from another country
yeah
yeah so uh so udokir uh a very early
role for him and he just goes like you
know it's not even over the top he goes
over the top and over the wall and
across the universe yeah and it's just
like and it's it's absolutely fantastic
i love it i mean i love the ridiculous
[ __ ] that he says in here yeah um one of
my favorite things is just like a really
brief thing where he's like i am
fulfilled but not yet but yeah yeah
but not yet
and just the way the the way
the way the [ __ ] script is written
and the way the dialogue is written the
way it's delivered it just doesn't
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
but it's hilarious it's i think it's
definitely intentional you know it's
supposed to be
just [ __ ] bizarre
i can see that i think uh um
this character this version of dr
frankenstein was was the inspiration for
herbert west too a lot of a lot of stuff
maybe everything columns is doing it
yeah it
seems to kind of come from this
character
um
it's a classic i i [ __ ] give it two
thumbs up man i mean i can't believe you
had never seen i had seen this
before like several years ago but i've
been meaning to like re-watch it and i
had forgotten how fun it was now i'm not
gonna lie there are some parts of it
that kind of drag yeah like there are
some scenes that you know of like like
at the beginning with the baroness
and the kids like going through the
countryside like in their you know in
their coach or whatever and that seems
to go on like way too long but honestly
uh the ridiculous [ __ ] that happens in
it is so ridiculous that it just like
makes up for it yeah and the tone here
is that you're not watching as any
comedy no it's trolling you you're
taking it serious
and then it just does but that's what
makes it funnier because everybody is
completely straight faced yeah they're
not winking at you they're playing
everything completely straight over the
top straight and it's hysterically
hysterically funny yeah i mean it's
obviously everyone's not gonna find it
funny it depends on what your sense of
humor is but you really do have to go
into this like thinking that yeah and
frank is standing this when he's trying
to make a couple and he's calling him
his perfect serbians yeah why serbians
who knows yeah because well his
explanation is they're supposed to be
like the in direct line from the ancient
greeks who were supposed to be like the
pinnacle of human evolution yeah but the
thing is his perfect serbians don't look
serbian they don't love it they look
scandinavian
so why do you just start with some damn
swedes
which that's part of the reason why
they're trolling you okay
and then
they're supposed to reproduce and the
the man the male one has to have a
[ __ ] large [ __ ]
voracious sexual appetite
and
the woman is supposed to be like as sexy
as possible but flat as
possible ass as possible
the dude the the the the alpha male that
he's trying to make
he mistakes a gay guy for alpha male so
they put the gay head on the [ __ ]
thing you know what i mean he's either
gay or asexual because he's talking
about going into a monastery but i think
there was some implication in there that
he was like maybe late in tomosexual
which is why he wasn't interested look
it's a game
it's pretty much not interested in women
they don't really get looking at the
dude's ass yeah
he's gay
they didn't really go too much because i
thought it was going to go more in that
direction but it doesn't really they
kind of play more around him being like
more asexual so frankenstein's uh
frankenstein's ideas about
heterosexuality we're all [ __ ] up he
thinks gay men are heterosexual he
thinks [ __ ] flat women that have no
sexual attributes or sexual desires are
the sexiest so everything's all [ __ ]
backwards
and then they don't look anything like
serbian so what the [ __ ] he calling
and the thing is they're doing this [ __ ]
straight
like like he really means it you know i
mean it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
and then
he has sex with them with the woman that
he made
but not really he just
penetrates or he goes in and then
reaches into a
breaks her wounds open where he
assembled her and then
jerks himself off with her i guess like
squishes himself around with her hand
like i said you can tell where
and honestly uh they're married to his
sister too so this and that's something
that they don't ever really address
it's brought up but it's kind of well
there's so much like other depraved [ __ ]
going on in there it's almost kind of
like an afterthought which is very very
funny and he's had children where the
children don't even look like they're
related which that's that was funny one
of the ginger the other one looks like
like a greek or something they're they
don't even look really that little girl
that's in that she was in a [ __ ] ton of
movies when she was a kid i think her
name is uh nicoletta elmi she wasn't i
recognized her immediately because i was
like oh my god she was in that giallo
movie uh who saw her die which i just
watched like a couple weeks ago she was
also in bay of blood she was in deep red
the dario argento movie and she was in
later in the 80s she was in demons the
lamborghini bava movie although i think
she retired or whatever like in the 80s
there's lots of nudity in it there's a
lot of sexual innuendos that sex is
happening that doesn't quite show it uh
but they let you know that it does
happen
uh they hint at people doing 69s through
the shots they hit at people blowing
each other but they never actually show
it
uh it's just a there is a male full full
frontal nutrition yeah there's some of
that and uh a lot of female nudity uh
but everything is kind of unsexy that's
another weird thing a lot of nudity but
there's no it's not
sexy everything is everything defeats
itself in the movie no matter what
happens there's an opposite that's
happening at the same time in the story
that negates it
i kind of read this and i'm actually not
the only person to read it like this but
it's almost kind of like not only a
parody
of frankenstein films and hammer films
because it definitely is trying to be a
hammer film and honestly um anti-hammer
yeah it it actually looks really nice uh
it's the same cinematographer i please
correct me if i'm wrong i'm pretty sure
it's the same cinematographer who worked
with dario argento sometimes yeah this
was like shot in italy so it's it was
largely italian uh crew yeah it's well
made yeah so
i'm not sure about the exteriors but for
sure like the interiors were shot in
rome yeah but um i i kind of feel like
other than it being like a kind of a
parody of that it's also kind of like
making fun of
the degenerate aristocracy yeah which i
kind of feel like you know what i mean
because you got uh baron frankenstein
and the baroness who like i said are
[ __ ] with their brother and sister
well they do they don't [ __ ] anymore but
so she said she's in a loveless
relationship so she's like going and
[ __ ] all the farm hands yeah while
he's like [ __ ] his experiments sort
of like because he knows about it he
sees it doesn't confront because i and
he goes i've never interfered with your
dirty sex life
like that
yeah
i mean he can speak english but i mean
this is pretty he uh i think he traveled
to uh england in his youth like to learn
english and uh so his and like i said
this was one of his very early films so
his accent and this is very very very
thick yeah so he's a very i know and
it's like i think that's like the best
thing about it i mean this has lines
like probably the most famous line in
this is to know death otto you have to
[ __ ] life
in the gallbladder yeah
it is a gallbladder
and the other guy goes but but they must
stop you you she will hurt him and then
spoil him
this [ __ ] funny [ __ ] he's just i mean
like i said i love udo care he's been in
like so many movies and i kind of feel
like
if seeing this you're like yeah that
dude's gonna be a [ __ ] legend because
like i said he chews up the scene or he
just chews all of it yeah and what's
funny is that i'm looking at it and he
looked instantly familiar and then once
uh oh okay i went back and looked at his
how many movies and then i recognized
who exactly he is yeah he's young as
hell in this very handsome very handsome
guy he's a very good looking dude and uh
i was just [ __ ] he's slamming this
character he's [ __ ]
dude and it took me a while to
understand the tone of the movie okay
yeah because at first tom's like wow the
acting of this is really attractive it's
supposed to be and i was like dude just
i mean everything wrong with this or
this is a well-made movie every mistake
in this is it's intentional i kind of
feel like it might be although i will
say
that
what they i think the original idea that
paul morrissey wanted to do was he
wanted it to be improvised yeah but
because you had a lot of actors like
udokir that didn't really do that or
weren't really good at improv
improvisation so he's like okay well
what we'll do is we'll just go day by
day so i'll kind of like write out
whatever your dialogue is supposed to be
on that day and then you learn that you
know day to day so it is kind of like uh
a little bit ramshackle i guess in that
way and you do have um i said we haven't
like said we've it happens in this story
but i was gonna uh
maybe we shouldn't spoil it but
it's free on [ __ ] well it's not
shutter shutter yeah and like i said if
you really want the nice [ __ ] and you
want to watch it in 3d the way it was
originally supposed to be
uh then you can buy the vinegar syndrome
uh two discs set because they they have
the 3d version make no mistake this is a
masterpiece yeah
it is it is great it's goofy as [ __ ] and
i kind of love it all this
improv that they were doing and just
making it up as they're going along
that's italian that's in the italian
genre to actually have a [ __ ] script
would kind of be
to not do not make the kind of movie
they're supposed to be making that's
what it's homaging yeah so you kind of
have to do it that way and then they
homage a lot of stuff and
i don't think i don't think the average
like normie pedestrian would get this
but people that watch a lot of movies
know exactly what's happening in this
yeah
you know you see how many movies were
influenced by this
a lot of stuff rips this movie off
well like i said this was a massive like
cult hit yeah uh you know and it
honestly
it kind of like you know it sort of
premiered it didn't really play like at
a lot of theaters and stuff but
particularly in the early 70s we got all
these weird-ass [ __ ] movies going
around this one really got a lot of like
buzz well andy warhol was associated
with it yeah all your creative types had
to see this movie and make a judgment on
it and it influenced a lot of them it is
a great movie it's a great movie it is
not what you think no it is it is what
you think it it's supposed to be an
awesome shitty movie awesome shitty
movie that's what it's supposed to be
yeah and it knows what it is but it's
not
but it's playing it straight
yeah it's not [ __ ]
it's taking itself real seriously but
that's the fun part of it yeah to me
to me like bad movies that take
themselves seriously whether
intentionally or unintentionally
are way funnier yeah yeah than ones that
are trying to be funny or self-aware you
know what i mean uh i will say too that
the uh
probably the other most famous guy
that's in this joe d'alessandro who
again uh you know discovered i guess by
andy warhol
and he's in this as nicholas the uh
randy farmhand
and he was actually it's hilarious
because in this movie pretty much
everyone's like europeans right and it's
just like it's so european that it hurts
but joe d'alessandro is from brooklyn
and when he talks like as soon as he
opens his mouth it's very very clear
that he's from brooklyn so it's like
really really funny to have this kind of
like modern brooklyn sounding dude like
around with all these like germans and
and serbians or whatever
he's like uh let's be charitable joe
d'alessandro is not a great actor okay i
mean it's all on purpose he's kind of
like a vacuous
void of a person yeah they get shots of
people just staring blankly yeah
and it's just kind of like you know
sometimes like you have there's like a
scene of him like udokir is just kind of
like what are you doing in this part of
the castle or whatever and he's just
like hamming it up like usual and then
joe d'alessandro is just like yeah yeah
it's just like so funny but joe
d'alessandro actually um pretty uh
pretty influential in you know a gay
cinema and he's actually kind of like a
big gay icon
and he was you know the rolling stones
album sticky fingers with the crotch on
the front yeah that's his crotch okay uh
also the first smith's album
that picture that's on the first smith
that's him too okay that's from the
movie uh flesh so he's uh himself he's
bisexual but he's kind of like a a big
like a gay icon he was in a lot of
i don't know if it was like gay porn but
he was in like a lot of uh you know gay
films that were like really ahead of
their time like in the early 70s and
it's interesting if you look at his
wikipedia but think he's still alive but
um if you look at his wikipedia page he
actually started out as like a [ __ ]
juvenile delinquent you know what i mean
he's like his mom was in prison for like
stealing cars and then he and then he
kind of went the same way because he was
in foster homes and he was like doing a
crime one time and the cop like shot him
in the leg and chill like that so but
then he kind of went on to become this
you know this icon like in underground
films particularly with this association
with andy warhol so it's just funny
record past can help you in certain
circles yeah well particularly in that
one because they loved like low lifes
you know what i mean that was kind of
like their big thing and um i think they
had street crit yeah exactly he was yeah
he had he had uh done the [ __ ] you know
but uh so yeah so he's in this and it's
funny because so he was the guy
see what happens is because you were
saying earlier about how uh you know
frankenstein udokir's character is
trying to make he's trying to
make the perfect woman and the perfect
man and he wants them to mate
and have children that will be under his
it's very like nazi eugenics kind of uh
thing yeah definitely and um
he wants them to have children that will
be like loyal to him and him only make
his own he's making his own race is what
he's yeah is what he's doing so he wants
like perfect people now notably he does
have his own two children perfect
serbians but i guess the implication
they don't say this outright but the
implication being that because he had
children with his sister
that they that they're like inferior
yeah even though the kids they don't
really talk much
but um
they they kind of like well they imply
that the kids are kind of like taking
after the parents yeah later on later on
uh because they do like and they are
like hiding behind paintings like
watching their mom [ __ ] the farmhand and
it's like all this other things
degenerate man but it's supposed to it
is
so like i said it's real gory there's
like tons of like eviscerations now the
special effects are not
you know great they're kind of like
cartoonish but it kind of like
especially like the beheading scene
because
what ends up happening because you were
saying before that he's he's so he's
trying to make this couple so the man
the woman's done he already he already
got her done yeah uh and like i said he
[ __ ] the wound or whatever and it's
like really weird and then it's like i
love that it's funny he does it in front
of this evan and otto his assistant
is just like he's
yeah
you filthy thing
he calls him filthy for watching him
watching him [ __ ] dead body that he
turned together and he's like make it
out with a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] up
movie you guys it's really [ __ ] up it
it it is funny it's but yeah it's
ridiculous but it's like it's straight
it's ridiculous it's funny it's uh it's
it's it is now
otto's
version of frankenstein i i'm pretty
sure uh gene wilder
watched that when he made young
frankenstein
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] gene wilder's
doing in his tone
some of it is kind of like the udo
akira's version
that over-the-top [ __ ] seems like i
think some of it came from that although
some of it might have been too because i
think they were homaging like befriended
bride of frankenstein from the 30s yeah
they were they were homage and i think a
lot of different fragrances like like
colin clive like you know played
frankenstein and he was kind of pretty
over the top too but i could imagine
gene wilder
tried to do this character
yeah i could imagine it
[Laughter]
but yeah so but what ends up happening
is that
why um why the [ __ ] doesn't work out
like when he's making the man because
he's sitting there going well he has the
man but the head that he wants because
his whole thing is i need the the head
slash brain of a man
that is
really um you know
has a strong like libido
because
that'll just yeah in a perfect serbian
nose or nasim as he says
uh so it'll just want to hump this
female creature all the time and they'll
make all these babies
so what ends up happening though is that
there's a mix-up because they're like
well they had one head and he's like
that one's not working out so they're
gonna go find another one and so they
decide as you would that they're gonna
go to the town brothel
and due to a misunderstanding at the
brothel
uh the one guy that they should have
taken the guy played by joe d'alessandro
who actually was a horn dog
um you know and was really into the
ladies
they instead end up with his sexless
like asexual best friend
uh sasha who's only at the whorehouse
because his friend nicholas is like hey
if you know before you join the
priesthood you know why don't we go to
the brothel and you can see what you're
missing out on so you can make an
informed decision yeah uh so
they think that sasha is the sex maniac
even though he's you know asexual slash
probably lately homosexual
so they gay yeah so i mean because they
do have like some scenes of him like
longingly looking at joe d'aless under
his butt yeah that's like that that's
which he went to the he went they're
taking him to the brothel to try to get
him to be straight yeah that's what's
happening
because he's not interested in women
they're trying to get him he wants to be
a priest with so you hang out with the
other guys yeah at the comment or
whatever you know
he goes to the goes to the [ __ ] house
and sits there and [ __ ] the the girl
is trying to put a move on and there's
no reaction he doesn't even like it
and then she leans up against him and he
just sits there and he's longingly
looking at his buddy's ass while it's
bouncing up and down
jenny's trying to be you know she's
trying to be forgiving oh well maybe
he's just like no it's obvious no i said
it's one of the other it's it's obvious
he's gay they're trying to tell you he's
gay
well a lizard gets out and
then the hookers run from the lizard and
then he runs out with the women too okay
to check and see if they're all right
okay and
udo and his buddy watch it and they go
oh look he is coming out and look two
women at once that's the man we need
but no basically the line was it's like
one man and two women yeah he must be
very powerful yeah
[Laughter]
they got this dude's head that they
think he's just this ultimate [ __ ]
alpha hetero you know [ __ ] superman
they're gonna put it on there and he's
gonna just be running after women no
they got the gay guy's head
okay [ __ ] get the gay head he's got the
gay guy's head he's not gonna be
interested in the female so yeah he's
gonna do one right kiss him yeah kiss
him and then they keep looking at him
kiss him because nothing's happening you
kiss her something's wrong yeah
he's not getting he's not getting it up
and [ __ ]
so that's you know that's what happened
is it is it great though yeah it's
[ __ ] great man
so then meanwhile crazy [ __ ] so he makes
this creature that obviously has sasha's
head on it it's a different body it was
like taller than he was normally um but
then also
uh nicholas the randy dude who was
friend of sasha's he like wakes up
because he gets knocked out he was like
super drunk like from the brothel he
gets knocked out his you know his friend
gets his head cut off and taken and they
just leave the headless body laying
there so he wakes up and he's just kind
of like huh well look at that you know
what it's because it's joe d'alessandro
he's not like reacting all that much so
he kind of like just buries the body
he's like i wonder what's going on there
but then he goes back to because he
works on the frankenstein's farm he's
like a farmhand or whatever
and uh he goes there and he's
starts [ __ ] the baroness because
she's just like oh this is a hot hunka
man you know and her husband's not
[ __ ] her anymore so she's basically
like okay well i'm gonna hire you as a
manservant and also like my personal
gigolo pretty much uh but the problem
arises that obviously
nicholas when he sees the creation he's
like hey that looks just like my friend
sasha's head except that's not his body
because that's way taller than he was
he's like what the [ __ ] happened what's
going on in here so that's kind of what
leads to
uh you know him trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
doctor
you know cutting up all the bodies and
everything this is a it's
i mean this movie is like i said it does
have some slow parts it's almost kind of
shot and i was like watching another
review of this and when they said this i
was kind of like yeah i see i see what
you're saying it's almost kind of shot
like a play you know what i mean like
there's a lot of like long shots with
like a lot of action but i kind of feel
like
there are some scenes like i said that
go on too long like there will be like
you know everyone's walking into the lab
or whatever and they'll like follow
their action like in real time as
they're like coming in the lab so some
of that could have been trimmed it's not
a real long movie i think it's only 90
minutes or 93 minutes something like
that
and um
so it does have like parts in it that
kind of drag like that but honestly
it's just so perverse
and so over the top and just so
funny like you have like all these
people chewing scenery and then you have
like joe d'alessandro like acting like
he's sleepwalking through the [ __ ] with
his brooklyn accent yeah and it's just
like and it's just just staring off it's
delightful and it's just like and
there's just weird [ __ ] in there like
like when uh joe d'alessandro and um his
name's nicholas like the character and
the baroness are like in bed together
she's doing this weird he's laying there
naked and she's doing this weird thing
where she's like slurping on his arm
and his arm and stuff and it's just i'm
just like what why and i think they
folded in those sounds too so it sounds
like
yeah yeah it's like
nursing his [ __ ]
what that was about they're just trying
i think they were just trying to show
like i said this sort of like a weird
the aristocracy and they're kind of like
degenerate they can't even have sex
normally yeah yeah they just have to do
like all this weird [ __ ] because
frankenstein was like that he couldn't
have any kind of normal sex or
relationship yeah it had to be like i
have to like stick my dick in a wound
you know what i mean or play with
people's
uh spleens or whatever and that
that sex is dirty and the sexiest of all
women were the sexless women basically
yeah you know it does kind of genderless
sexless women were the sexiest which is
just all these weird [ __ ]
kind of twisted concepts of that don't
work nothing he did worked can we also
talk about how awesome his [ __ ] death
scene is
holy [ __ ] yeah
you guys sitting up and you're just
gonna take a forever to die and he keeps
like he has this long speech yeah it
doesn't speak [ __ ] yeah and here's
the thing the shit's played straight it
is like a serious yeah
it's just keep reminding yourself it's
not they're fuc they're trolling you
they're [ __ ] trolling the [ __ ] yeah i
mean i think they wanted to make the
most absurdist yeah it's real absurd
take on the frankenstein legend that
they could possibly do and just make it
as degenerate as possible like what they
could get away with and they're they're
putting on a show they're putting on a
real good show it's just just think of
it like there's people putting on a show
that's what it is they're putting on it
i mean as i said it's not going to be
for everybody because you have to have i
guess like a particular sense of humor
yeah um but i mean
yeah like honestly i think this movie is
hilarious yeah it is um but and he and
you also thought it was hilarious i mean
it's just really really funny you can't
at first i'm watching this going man
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks
they were trolling me
i got it i was 15 20 minutes into it oh
they're trolling me oh yeah you're like
c yeah yeah they they knew what trolling
was back then yeah they they they didn't
have the 70s they didn't really have a
word for it but not really but yeah they
still did it yeah uh yeah so like i said
this was rated x when it first came out
um because mostly because i mean the sex
isn't hardcore it's like softcore they
just talk there is like full frontal
male nudity no erections or anything
because i think that's one of the
distinctions lots of female nudity but
[ __ ] they did that yeah in every in
every movie yeah you didn't really see
that but yeah a lot of the implications
are kind of [ __ ] up yeah you stand
there and a girl just his head just goes
down so you know he's [ __ ] giving her
head and the same kind of thing is
happening she's giving another dude they
don't show showing you just show her
head going down he's standing there and
then dude looking bored like i'm not in
this movie
i'm not in this glow of me but i'm not
in this that dude looks like he's
getting to fall asleep and he didn't do
it did that [ __ ] on purpose they were
doing it on purpose they were like look
just just just just stand there and look
pretty in there yeah you just that's
kind of that's kind of your thing jordan
just stand there and look pretty but
yeah that's
[Laughter]
and this was actually on the list the
infamous british list in the 1980s of
video nasties so i think it was
originally released i think it had a
minute cut out but i don't think the
british would get this back in the day
but it was released uh uncut a few years
back 2006 or something like that but um
it is like i said it is very gory uh you
know they do show like a you know
beheading and lots of disemboweling lots
of disembowlings uh you know just guts
coming at you and um you know it looks
fake obviously this was a fairly low
budget movie and it was the early 70s
yeah so it's not like i kind of feel
like it's it's just like a step above
like h.g lewis you know what i mean
where it's like blood feast or something
where they did use i think they did use
like real um like sheep lungs and [ __ ]
like that like in various parts but yeah
um originally
this was 3d
which like i said if you watch it
knowing that then some of the shots make
a lot more sense like part of uh you
know udokir's like death scene with this
big pole like coming out his mid section
that has like a spleen or something
hanging off the end of it and it's kind
of like right in the camera and then
there's one scene where otto kills the
housekeeper
and
she kind of falls
over like a grate and then like the
cameras underneath and like all her guts
kind of fall out like toward the camera
so there's a lot of like shots like that
where
you know you can tell that it was
originally presented in 3d yeah now this
is an italian flick all right it's it's
not a jello though
it's an italian flick pretending to be a
german flick pretending to be a hammer
pretending to be a hammer move
and it it it successfully does that it's
got a [ __ ] real strong german
weird [ __ ] german trashy feel to it
it is very skeezy but that's what i
really like about it i love purpose i
love like these kind of like euro trash
movies they're so fun it's all
intentional they're so fun and they're
like so smutty yeah and well because you
were saying last night she's like leave
it to the europeans to like something
make something that's trashy and classy
it's different yeah it's trying to be
classy
at the same time that's what i like
about them that's what i like about it
it's like we're doing like these like
already art films like we have all this
classical like score and everything like
that and then like you know there's
sister [ __ ] and necrophilia
they're dressed nice and they're in
[ __ ] palaces and [ __ ]
and uh
all this like an upper crust upper class
[ __ ]
kind of
uh look to look and feel to them but
then they're just saying [ __ ] really
perverted [ __ ] and just like yeah
kind of like reminding me of those
[ __ ] early 80s and late 70s
[ __ ] bdsm comic books
yeah remember like little witches and
[ __ ] like that yeah like i think it's
called three witches or little witches
and all kinds of weird it's like that
yeah it is it is very canned wanda type
[ __ ] wicked wanda yeah wicked wanda
uh it is very camp and it's really fun
if you're in the right frame of mind uh
you know real gory lots of smut and it's
just i don't know it's i i have a really
good time every time i watch it it's
just so silly and over the top udokir is
wonderful i love him and everything and
that's kind of like i kind of feel like
this was you know the start of his
uh horror genre journey because he was
just so crazy and memorable in this yeah
that everybody's like yeah let's get
that guy yeah like and that's what you
hire him for you hire him to like just
go all the way over the top i gotta say
i liked him better than klaus kensky
yeah i mean yeah
because i mean this can do some [ __ ]
weird-ass [ __ ] but he's along that lines
klaus kinski you could tell that he like
not was legit crazy yeah he's insane
whereas udo kiara never struck me as
like he just strikes me as like just
kind of a fun dude he can pull it off
klaus kinski seems like a legitimate
crazy person
and also really creepy yeah evidently
you just can't work with it yeah and
he's just like just really really
difficult which like i said i never i
don't know a lot about um udokir like
his personal life or what anything like
that but he doesn't come across
he doesn't come across as creepy or
weirdness i mean he is a little bit
weird but
he doesn't come across the same way that
klaus klaus kinski actually kind of
gives me the creeps pervert yeah but
like you know what i mean but udo care
doesn't i always thought he was like
delightful uh because he was like [ __ ]
he was in suspiria too he was in like
[ __ ] [ __ ] tons of stuff but yeah so
if you want to see the 3d one then you
can go and buy the uh the two disc set
which has like the theatrical cut it's
been all restored it looks really really
nice
and they also have the 3d when it comes
to the glasses and everything it's the
old school 3d with the red and the blue
um and from some people that i've that
reviewed that they said oh the 3d looked
really cool and actually they
recommended that you should probably
watch it in 3d because that's how it was
you know originally intended to be
presented and uh there's you know it's
really fun with all the guts like being
thrust in your face and everything like
that and also you know you could see joe
d'alessandro's butt in 3d so that's nice
uh but if you don't want to buy it then
you can watch it on shutter at the
moment shutter just added this and uh
blood for dracula which is i see that
one too yeah which is also paul
morrissey obviously they shot it uh just
right after this one and it has pretty
much the same cast and crew okay playing
pretty much the same characters i don't
think it's quite as smutty or gory but
um some people like it better okay you
know what i mean but i i haven't seen it
for a really long time so i recommend
this one i think it's a required viewing
this is something yeah i mean if you're
into cult films you kind of need to see
this uh how you feel about it like i
said that's going to be up to you
it is yeah it's a really fun perverse
just crazy ass [ __ ] movie and yeah
the perversion is mental yeah it doesn't
matter
it's just the [ __ ] that they say yeah
pretty much yeah yeah but yeah so it's a
lot of fun go to shutter watch it tell
us what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one bye
you